I phone not only created a category it  created a benchmark by which all other  smartphones are measured iphone 6 and  iphone six-plus are widely considered  the best smartphones in the world  recently we sold our 700 million iphone  the iphone is growing stronger than ever  in fact if you look at last quarter we  sold at a rate of double the rate of  growth of double the industry this is  phenomenal for business this big to be  growing by fifty percent this led iPhone  propelled iphone to be the top selling  smartphone in the world but we are most  proud of this the customer SAT score of  99 percent for iphone 6 and 6 plus these  numbers are unheard of